hey what's up Tonya Dwyer hear me with
Andy BAM when Andy a fully trailer came
out I know it today is fallout day baby
I woke up especially already to watch
this check it out it's a police standby
screen zooming asthma television that's
a motif we've seen before into a
post-apocalyptic world Brian Fargo
presents fallout 1 look at this it's all
going so well here and then zoom out and
oh it's all happening bad so nice little
shout back to fall at one there and also
to the fallout 3 various trailer said
that the the launch trailer had a zoom
left my television the teaser trailer as
we see here and which didn't show much
compared to this teaser trailer I assume
dad from a radio so just remembered last
time with the first time we saw fallout
3 was just this and I brotherhood of
steel shot so but that was epic because
it was like yo 3d [ __ ] the ink
spots was used in this trailer the the
the track I don't want to set the world
on fire the ink spots was also used in
the fall out one trailer so that's the
intro to the game actually sorry you're
right this is the intro this is a song
called maybe and the ink spots were also
used in this one it's actually a
different song each time even though to
use that same riff yeah the don't don't
don't don't ya and this song is called
it's all over but the crying this is man
those guys really they must've been set
in the world on fire in the 30s with
positive music yeah and this is a scene
where used to and fall out the radiation
King and television there this is a
house which has been which is left after
some nuclear horribleness happens as you
so rightly were saying this morning this
is a loot cave yeah all that's left to
get is the cereal exactly lets up to
some cereal in this lots of a shot a
shed its your game blast radius and yeah
that's amazing on the on the kitchen top
there or look at this avery how it cuts
back and forth there we don't see that
in the game and so they could just be
doing it for atmospheric building you
don't atreya but they've shown quite a
lot of that this world so who knows just
a mr. handy robot of course holding
would you know it's some sugar bombs hey
all right some pre-apocalyptic cereal
unraid e ated sugar pie it'll be
radiated by the time you get to eat us
his name and here we have a game or a
dog with other table there doesn't look
at too dissimilar from dog meesh this is
another german shepherd which I think
you'll prob
we be spending a lot of time with and
father for I thought is Riley hahaha so
many German Shepherds a video game and
you're right the sugar bombs on the
table so it turns out mr. handy may be
the last the last time he served cereal
to ease this a wonderful family this
young family actually we can see you
only just got out of the box to mr.
handy boxes there on the right so do i
scale too much yeah the box held up all
right turns out cardboard just hide in
cardboard if the nuclear fallout come
and that we zoom into this first thing
to say I guess is that color I'm
obviously a lot more color here and we
see a little nuka-cola truck on the kids
bedside table there a little stand and
but yeah like even in this area this
post the pocket like that blue is like
striking yeah so I'm wondering after
gonna step away from the sort of
reserved color palette of 43 in New
Vegas although New Vegas was a bit more
colorful than three was and I one thing
i liked here is that this really looks
like the rep con rockets the this is
from New Vegas the rocket engineering
production company often Nevada and
which you might remember I do I remember
that quest being amazing actually pretty
solid Christ and then we see a we see
some parents with a baby which which
maybe you in the game oh dude baby I
guess that's like a thing fall three
right you're the baby that's true that's
a total team I guess the thing would be
if you were to be the baby and you came
out and not that much time has passed
but we'll get into that in the secretary
cuz the bond the Boston is we were later
to find out in this game and he's
looking a lot better than the west coast
one somebody looking and so here we have
a fallout dog running outside running
outside to a very familiar-looking seen
this is video that's follow yeah this is
very evocative of regular eyes fall out
and this shot here is not look guys are
we watching the excom that never was
yeah that ex-con game that never came
out yeah it does look a lot like a
1940's America have folks packing up
presumably because they've heard that
the attack is coming that the warheads
are inbound yeah this is interesting
because like I remember such a massive
question for a three to find a tree and
here I have trees all over the place and
granted they're not doing too well but
this looks like you know there are
leaves on the ground and there are
bushels that are not flowering maybe to
their utmost maybe not flowering like
this Jonathan Blow situation is he here
but yeah so those leaves are to be
pote like from before the bomb went off
they lasted a really long time or the
time isn't that long so or if they still
have leaves and this is just winter
something on yeah cuz look at this
situation on the right like this bush
would read on us yeah there's just like
this type of maybe they've just been a
little bit more liberal with what I
chart yeah with the art design or maybe
function is a little bit different
there's a skeleton on the ground there
presumably one of these lovely people
who are trying to get into and one of
the vaults we see the army guys they're
wearing what we now know in the fall
universe has Brotherhood of Steel suits
but of course that's just with the army
war I mean prior to the war power armor
for everyone exactly and then we see a
prepare for the future the sort of
vault-tec slogan we've seen that poster
a lot of times in previous Fallout games
and that was a sort of the nice little
intro we got a bunch of a little sort of
flavor for the universe and then they
show us what we're gonna look forward to
vault 111 what were we gonna call it
vault 111 uh 11 what our boss in
corresponding told us oh really yeah
Eddie makuu eddie makuch at Boston 111
he's so dedicated to reporting on the
news that he's actually in Boston right
now yeah on the streets he's on the
scene baby and this is a sort of a
regular vault where you just walk in but
it looked like something like this might
be the elevator you come down it cuz
it's like a top loaded vault yeah there
might be two stages to this one or two
entrances who knows well anyway cuz this
little section whatever this yeah this
is very evocative of the fall 83 intro
where you you see the waistline for the
first time you don't have I protection
which is bad you don't see you always
get son bloom when you come out of the
bunkers and this is very evocative of
just regular fallout as well big old
wasteland yeah I'll lay down front of
you go yeah go for it see what trouble
you can get into yeah wonder how many
towns you'll get to choose to blow up or
not in this one I wonder if that's a
helipad of some sort doc little bit
maybe that vault is required to store or
like you know all the vaults gonna have
a thing a theme a social experiment or
something like that there is this one is
like helicopters come and save you or so
I don't know we'll see and there is a
fan fiction editor for vault 111 of the
better being the Christmas vault I don't
think that's being used here and one
thing that is though is Boston the city
of Boston this is at the bunker hill
monument in Danton Boston Massachusetts
so we know where the game is set now
and there's a lot of motifs are Boston
scenery used here this is the USS
Constitution you know much about this
boat well I've been on this boat oh you
have yeah it's a pretty cool Bo's got
lots of cannons restored and sitting
there looking presumably than two
rockets on the back of it when you saw I
I mean it could have been underwater you
know yeah which I given retrofitted to
to be some sort of warship maybe they're
gonna go to China on this boat before
the war okay yeah now they've never
stuck they just built a store underneath
it like everything yeah or maybe they've
done this post-apocalyptic Lee and
they're gonna like try and make an
airship out of this yeah who knows those
possibilities are to find out could be
rivet city version two here we have an
interesting scene this is Scoleri square
in boston which I've not been to but
I've read alphabet is sort of like the
the downtown bar restaurant area cool
but a mysterious stranger there of
familiar asteri mysterious strangers
from the first two games and you were
reminding me earlier of course it's a
park in fallout 3 yeah it's a perk where
the dice rolls when you're doing vats
and a guy in this sort of get up a
trench coat and a hat and all that he
shows up and just in a guitar riff plays
it like it's you know the forties
mystery riff plays and he shoots someone
does massive damage so massive dama it's
a cool thing that's been in the fallout
universe since the beginning yeah muscle
reference and the memory then there as
well as probably some some bad nonsense
happens in there and the many details or
what if they give the mysterious
strangers like a faction oh they became
like talkable like actual card yeah
maybe write a Brahmin confirmed got a
caravan right there is a bunch more
Brahmin in the background and I like the
the storm that's coming in here I'm
wondering are they gonna do some sort of
weather nonsense oh my god cuz they've
not really done that that would be that
would add a lot to the atmosphere he
absolutely and what else we got we all
here is interesting got some mobs yeah
these look like are they in power armors
I Brotherhood I try to tell ya big blows
it you're awesome lighting going on as
ever lots of broken up buses and stuff
maybe that's a reference to fallout
three straight who knows and again we've
sort of a lot of like it seems like
getting closer to the city in these
shots yeah and now we have one of the
robot handyman and we have a protector
Tron yeah
tikona which were they were introduced
into new vegas i think and yeah
protector John's are a staple of the
franchise as well here we have a
construction site all in all a Boston
seems to have not been head is badly no
I sorta certainly seems like it's held
up pretty well yeah definitely
comparable to what we saw on the west
coast which would make sense because
they were you know I guess the Chinese
were closer to them so presumably more
warheads on that side and there's
probably some some sort of deep fiction
about it that'll explain something up
but yeah our friend the protector Tron
here and this is inching this is a whole
of a Bose that's been sort of converted
into something and a [ __ ] Meyer lurk
yeah Meyer lurks confirmed oh those
cribs was jerk look at as sand it's
awesome looking it looks great i like
the the wind that's happening on the on
the leaves there may be some we got some
witcher 3 maybe turn off that wind to
get fallout 3 for running properly and
this is another great showing of the the
new lighting stuff that's happening a
fallout 4 cuz like so many animations
don't look super incredible and
obviously this is an open world game so
you kind of have to you know be
realistic about it but the lighting here
looks pretty sick that volumetric stuff
is is really good and this is like
follow three hey look remember
overpasses but look we have lighting now
it's pretty even better so I'm into the
graphics I know a lot of people are
saying they don't like them but hmm I
don't know next-gen overpasses there's
also a little remember that little
poster in the background a little [ __ ]
thing we'll get to that in a second and
here's the next shot I can't think what
this is I was wondering if it was those
crazy beasts like hardest ones in New
Vegas yes guys but they don't look the
exact same so I don't know if this is a
new type of enemy or looks nicely
turning one I like the volumetric fog
situation happening here as well yeah
the color correction stuff on this shot
is amazing I hope the game renders it
like this for sure absolutely hopefully
also showing off to sort of you know
they've shown a lot of city but then
also you know we got a bunch of crazy
wasteland stuff here vertebrates
confirmed back in the game course the
enclave used a ménage I think was the
requested where you got that you got one
in you gone for the Brotherhood of Steel
as well perhaps at once idea and yeah
verta birds we see a couple of shots
with these little bad boys in it so I
wonder if they'll take that tech they
used in the the Dragonborn expansion
pack for Skyrim and get some aerial
stuff in the game
you said you think this looks like rage
you had these enemies just have a rage
quality to their animation so I'm like
is this it tech no yeah well they do own
it now so who knows and yeah super fast
song bees we're used to seeing these and
bad boys yeah calling you smooth skins
and whatnot but of course these ones are
the ones that they get way more attack
on Sadie ated yeah hopefully vacillate
you take care of them a little bit
better than trying to shoot them a zoo
we haven't seen if there's any bats in
this bad boy yeah um so this is
interesting so this first of all is just
been way so it's where this send the Red
Sox and note that diamond right yes
that's a symbol of what i think is
coming up next so it opens up this thing
opens up and then we're into i think
you're inside Fenway in this shot in a
city that's been built inside the walls
cuz Fenway is is I've seen it it's
enclosed hmm more than like a lot of
baseball was a green monster yeah wall
and wash and it's like in the middle of
the city so like it'd be a great place
to build us a city you know from the
ashes of another cities because it's
protected and and the diamond city
surplus that's on that sign right there
has the same symbol so I'm guessing this
is inside the Fenway pattaya minh city s
waters and yeah lots of baseballs it's
written area baseball memorabilia store
here baseball bats waters it does also
guy dressed up as a in a baseball get up
in a socks and actually like the
Warriors Yankee Stadium when I saw us
first of all probably not that big
baseball bat open the top left corner as
well and then yeah noodle store why not
power noodle catch a lot of people in
this city just hanging out right like
the chemi Cara thing in the background
there's a lot of like established new
brands which is not something you saw a
lot of you saw a lot of old brands and
fall out but like this stuff kind of
looks a bit a bit new looks like the
world's been like this for a little
while and so yeah if that's inside
Fenway that's Sanskrit
yeah I love cities like that info
universe yeah they repurposed something
yeah and this is interesting because you
think that this is the polar of your
statue which is Dan town in Boston and
we think that's the Old North Church
it's it's not exactly that close to the
statue in Rio Boston but it's a pretty
good approximation and you made a good
an interesting point about this shot it
could be pre-war because everything's
still intact and there's a now leasing
sign still on that building over there
on the right yeah there's also this
airship situation yeah and like how many
big airships are there in the
post-apocalyptic world like I don't
think there's many or else there be way
more transportation between cities
cities and yeah which they seem to be
pre isolated and the tens don't look
that beat up like the city's don't look
too beat up but they look kind of crazy
in comparison to this one which
obviously it's a nighttime shot but then
also like those look at us like it looks
relatively normal yeah maybe I mean I
think Boston maybe not got heard they
didn't get hit yeah the nukes or this is
like you said in the past I guess roll
yeah find out there's a lot of
references to not the way to see there's
a vertibird there just a bad in the last
shot of that yeah barely see it you can
just see coming in when the sweeping
over there who stalked you so here's
this is interesting this sort of our our
gasoline and diesel and infusion which
is right there we've also got above
Brotherhood of Steel guy here this is a
supposed for a couple of little things
here yeah written that might be worth
worth checking in on first of all the
galaxies news is the g NN sign here so
gnr radio was galaxy news radio which is
where your boy three dog was yeah as a
GN n could be galaxy news network
perhaps yeah a bigger one the TV version
of that maybe who it might be maybe
three there was word the three dogs said
that he had worked on something yeah I
think he leaked something a while ago
like a year ago oh yeah am so maybe he's
back doing that on camera this time yeah
and there's a another sign in the
background there for and for follow up
here hey I thought it said fallout has
actually fallen salads and the rest of
boxes in the back the nuka-cola thing on
the right as well sign up on the side of
the building and that are in our thing
again like the war was fought over
resources so it's a little nod to like
what
the downfall of humanity
here's a nice little shot at
massachusetts state house there in the
foreground yeah and this this building
in the background is interesting you
were sort of mentioning it I wonder if
it's under construction that was used
you make maybe when the bombs hit or
maybe it's sitadelli right yeah like
crazy looking oh and it's in a bunch of
shots or perhaps and perhaps it's a more
feature in the in the game yeah but look
this is probably the shot which just
shows to you how much different this
city is to every city in Fallout yeah
because this looks like the top you
wouldn't know that this shot here
wouldn't tell you that nuclear fallout
has happened because the tops of these
buildings look like the tops of any
building yeah and the state house is
still intact it's just a little rusty i
guess like the it's you know not shiny
yeah you compare it to something like
what DC looked like in fallout 3 and
devastated yeah even even the Commodore
building like even those buildings were
like busted to [ __ ] like this is I this
actually looks kind of okay so this is
it yeah this is the top of the the 101
and vault which is this yeah top loaded
vault right beside the residential yeah
here's this is 111 bought for sure cuz
you can see it on the floor there hmm
I'll try to get inside before the bombs
go on yeah oh I'm lucky for you lady
with a baby in the foreground here on
the left dude on the right so maybe
maybe that's not you as the baby
permeates through the series man that's
one ugly looking explosion I wonder if
we're gonna see some of this I wonder if
this is gonna be like a prologue part or
this is gonna be yeah like flashbacks
that you play during the game maybe it's
hard to say but they sure had to do some
post effects to make this look better
than it does yeah fair enough so who
knows if it's like it seems like one of
those cutscenes this is just kind of at
the beginning or some thrown in yeah
well what Wayne see yeah here's our
friend Riley from call of duty again or
dog made making his return I think this
is perhaps the most telling is like the
third chapter of the trailer yeah and
it's definitely the one that's all
praises to me yes so we'll get into this
so this is the is obviously some power
armor power armor in fallout 3 and
follow one and two you have to like
level up together for like three you
have to get a specific Park to use this
power armor I think this shot here is
probably the most important shot of the
whole trailer okay cuz this power armor
there let's do let's do a piece by piece
this power armor looks like it's being
upgraded and it's being assembled yes
it also looks like there are some
weapons on the Left above that little
pair Fall Out Boy bobblehead yeah like
on the board there that are always cuz
there's a laser rifle there there is a
power glove I think at the top but some
of these look like weapon components
right like haven't been quite assembled
all the way yeah um yeah but who knows
like if and there's a minigun underneath
some blankets over the over there on the
right we have this sort of a vault Tec
poster which almost looks like it's got
the perks on us right it's actual
trading cards maybe pinned up or
something and then beside that as a
magazine rack and of course you
collected magazines all the way through
all the fallout games but they were
never really for anything like so gave
you like ability of yeah yeah could rely
candy mans thing and get more like
repair yeah but imagine if you were
collecting them imagine if this was your
home you're like world yeah this is your
home base yeah so that's so that leads
into some theory crafting that we're
gonna do well get into it a little bit
but yeah here we have the Paris armor
which is obviously being built together
some nuka-cola stuff in the background
top left shelf that some other little
bits and bobs I wonder if this is like
it's like your home yeah like your
inventory or something and so doggy runs
out so this is inching this is the same
this petrol station this gas station is
that or our brand as well and here we
have a you're sort of your vault 101
dude getting at new pip-boy check it out
what have they improved as so this is
slightly different to the pip-boy 3000
in that first of all you always needed a
glove with the pit boys you don't need a
glove with this one and perhaps the most
stupid design decision ever on the pit
boy was that it will always went on your
left hand yeah but the dials were on the
left of the unit so if you tried to use
your right hand you had to cover it yeah
you have to cover the screen like Steve
Jobs was not involved in the design of
the [ __ ] fit boy so this one they've
swapped the controls over to the right
side which means complete sense yeah and
obviously doesn't need a glove it's not
on either so we don't know really what's
you know what it does yet but uh you can
rub a dog in and I'm pretty good and
then here we go he talks he what
happened to follow the dude talks he's a
troy baker is that boston in the
background so much like Troy bigger any
why is he speaking so this is
interesting right so we there was a
leaked
manuscript a while ago which had some
sort of protagonist talking and had some
scripts and dialogue so the idea of a
talking main protagonist and fallout has
been a rumor that's been going for a
while this one all but seems to confirm
it obviously we don't have full
confirmation yet but it definitely tells
his hat towards that and I guess what do
you think it out right off the bat I'm
not against it in let it they better
have a female version too yes because of
course you could pick your gender on
race and why not in Pollock all of them
all of them yeah so yeah that'll be
instinct if they have like a fem shep
kind of situation they kind of would
really want to consider you made of like
role playing that this game does and
that's the other aspect of the role
playing is that like one of the things i
like about skyrim and fall out and it's
different to say something like with the
witcher where you play as garrett is
that you can very much transport
yourself into that character you can
make your own world yeah so if they're
gonna have the character talking does
that mean that he or she just talks
during you know conversations that
sounds cool or doesn't mean that the
character is actually a specific
character like Captain chapter Shepherd
and there you know you can just change
gender but there it is a specific person
and they have some sort of a you know
roush to the old world that they keep
going back to where they have like a
story that is very much there's I'd
obviously you did in 43 as well with
your with Liam Neeson being your dad
yeah but the greatest if out but those
are games to and if they do have a voice
character they may have to change this
is that you never really break I mean
you can control from third person but it
looks bad cuz the movements weird but it
never like breaks yeah so his first
person any even when you enter a
dialogue it just does that nice zoom in
shot right it's like nice or is that
Jang I think it's cool cuz it like it's
better than it's better than keeping it
far away because the composition to me
is just like awkward like it's too wide
and it like zooms in it's like all right
cool dialogue and then you have it there
and it's like very in your face and
focused and it's like if they have him
voice that might be weird so they
haven't had like a reverse shot like her
own we'll have to see obviously the
witcher 3 was a game what's tons of
dialogue which ended up having it being
voiced the whole way and some
maybe this is just that there's the
dragon fall and into the future this
definitely seems like they're going to
on the face of it like it kind of looks
like oh it's a new fancy looking fallout
and it's being set in the new city but
and you know I think there are some nods
to some very interesting things here
with the power armor and with the way
Boston looks with the sort of you know
what era fallout is this being taken in
is this like you know is this closer to
the the is it more in the future is it
closer to when the attacks happened but
it just wasn't hit as bad you know not
much information happened in California
was already here say so like who knows
what was actually going on and even as
far away is from DC you know because
obviously DC got hit and last thing to
say I guess is that bethesda game
studios are making it that's the website
and it said on xbox one playstation 4
and pc at the last room is that we have
is that them and this was a rumor before
this trailer actually came out was that
a Todd Herod might be doing some sort of
a long presentation at the Bethesda
conference and that the other big rumor
everyone's saying is that we may see
this in 2015 they did it with a Skyrim
they had sky Ramesh they an answer that
the vgas on spikes and then it was at
the following November so it was within
12 months so yeah who knows but Andy
thank you so much for joining me today
on this very long breakdown of the
fallout 4 trailer to him I was never
changed I that's food trailers never
change and for more coverage of all I
for stay tuned to gamespot com thanks
very much for watching
you